um i think one of the most remarkable
things that uh we found during the asap
program and and again uh the osap
program uh was a 24-month program that
started
in uh 2008 and ended in 2010
but you know for the first time we had a
large team we had about 50 people who
were employed full-time at osap and then
we had 22 million dollars allocated
through the defense intelligence agency
for a two-year period so
it's very rare in the ufo field to have
the luxury of resources and being able
to study people over long periods of
time after you know they've encountered
ufos so i guess one of the most
remarkable sort of
um discoveries that we made uh during
the asap program was
the intense medical effects
that that uh that some of these uh ufo
um
cases
cause in in in some people i'll give you
an example um
one of the one of the sentinel cases
that we actually investigated over
about a year actually and and it went
into almost a two-year investigation
was that this biotechnologist and his
daughter were driving towards bend
oregon in their in their vehicle on
their way home and the daughter notices
three small ufos
uh bluish-colored that were darting
around in the field beside them
once she noticed them they immediately
made a beeline for the vehicle as they
were driving and uh one of them went
right across the windshield one of them
went uh came into the car
and and went right across uh both the in
their field of view went right across
the uh the windshield
inside the vehicle but the third one
actually went through the left shoulder
of this biotechnologist
went through the upper thoracic cavity
and then emerged from the right shoulder
and then shot out through the
the window right in front of the
daughter i mean this was a terrifying
episode for the for the daughter
especially uh she was witnessing all of
this
but you know within um i would say 24 to
48 hours uh this guy woke up the
following day with the let the left side
of his face was all sunburned
um his his ear had started swelling his
eye he was started
losing the sight in his left eye
within a week or
a couple of weeks he started losing his
hair on the left side of his head and
you know luckily we had on contract md
phd
a couple of md phds
um really sort of as as people who could
get deep into medical investigations and
look at medical injuries so we deployed
one of these people uh you know on this
case and he followed he followed this
guy over many many months but um it
turned out that
a few months after this this event had
happened
he came down with a rare form of ductile
carcinoma
that locally was not metastatic so it it
did not metastasize
and over a two year period went through
a lot of a lot of health
issues
but in terms of being able to document
all of that we were very very fortunate
that we had access to blood samples
taken
from this guy before the incident and
then there were multiple blood samples
taken
after the incident
so we were able to
piece together a medical forensic sort
of picture of what had happened
before and uh and after this incident
and we could document you know
rises and falls of various immune immune
system parameters within this guy uh we
we we saw that there were dramatic
changes in neutrophil lymphocyte ratios
over time and you know this was for from
a an awesome
ufo investigation point of view we think
this was one of the sentinel cases
because
we we had resources and we were able to
we had the luxury of following this guy
over a year and a half to two years
after the incident and as i said we had
blood samples taken before the incident
so we were actually able to
postulate about cause and effect and the
sort of the dramatic increase in adverse
health symptoms that this guy had
uh
suffered um we were able to say with
reasonable confidence that he suffered
pretty well all of those after the uh
close encounter with this uh small blue
orb um so that that's that was the case
and we had uh several other cases
that uh bass asap encountered that sort
of um you know looked at the medical
injury aspect and that was one of the
things that really surprised me
during the mis the niz era we did not
encounter too many of those cases um you
know we were all the time database in
cases
from um you know we had about 1 800
separate ufo investigations under our
belt by the time the nids database uh
went on ice which was about 2003
um but we never saw in in terms of boots
in the ground investigations of ufo
effects we never saw the sort of level
of medical injury uh that we saw sort of
you know up close and personal with a
few of these cases so i guess that's one
of the things that really surprised me
from the awesome uh series of
investigations
did that person feel any burning
sensation or any sensation at all when
the orb went through him
well he he actually did feel a sort of
really weird sort of uncomfortable
um it wasn't painful or or
anything he he felt sort of um
discombobulated and sort of out of sorts
as this thing was traveling through his
body it was almost like
a large it felt like a very very large
bubble that was moving through his body
he actually did feel the movement but he
didn't feel any pain or he didn't feel
any discomfort he just felt
uh i would say it was sort of a version
of mild vertigo